Thanks to the memorable characters they brought
to life on the big screen and on our TVs,
these actors will never really leave us.
In fact, they'll always be there exactly the
way we remember them.
They'll never be more than a few clicks away.
Former child actor Jon Paul Steuer, who played
a young Klingon on Star Trek: The Next Generation,
died on January 1st at the age of 33.
Steuer began professionally acting at the
age of four, and was the first actor to play
Alexander, the mostly-Klingon son of Worf
on Star Trek: The Next Generation.
He portrayed the character in one episode,
"Reunion," and other actors went on to play
the role at various ages.
"Why can't I stay with you?"
"You deserve a home."
He's perhaps best known for playing Brett
Butler's eldest son on the sitcom Grace Under
Fire from 1993 until leaving the show in 1996.
"You're not sitting up here making plans to
be dysfunctional, are you?"
"What's dysfunctional?"
He later said he quit acting in part because
of Butler's erratic behavior and controversies
surrounding the series.
His death was announced on the Facebook page
of the rock band P.R.O.B.L.E.M.S, in which
Steuer sang under the name Jonny P. Jewels
for about a year.
"Watch out for Salami Sam!"
Former child actor Joseph Wayne Miller made
his breakthrough in the 1995 comedy Heavyweights.
According to TMZ, he died in his sleep on
January 9th at the age of 36.
Miller played the character of Salami Sam
in Heavyweights, which was co-written and
produced by Judd Apatow.
In a statement to Page Six, Apatow said:
"We could not have loved spending time with
him more.
He made everyone around him so happy.
What a terrible loss."
"Hey, what's up?
I'm Verne Troyer."
Verne Troyer stood at two feet eight inches,
and was born with achondroplasia dwarfism,
a condition that causes cartilage to not properly
convert to bones, often resulting in undersized
arms and legs.
In 2012, he told Jonathan Ross:
"You're born kind of proportioned, and, you
know, you look pretty much normal except for
being small."
He grew up in an Amish community in Michigan
and achieved fame when he debuted opposite
Mike Myers in 1999's Austin Powers: The Spy
Who Shagged Me.
Troyer had more than 50 acting credits in
movies and on television, including roles
as Griphook in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone and Coach Punch Cherkov in The Love
Guru.
Verne Troyer died on April 21st at the age
of 49.
According to People, his death was noted by
the coroner as possibly being a suicide via
alcohol poisoning.
An announcement on Troyer's Facebook page
read:
"It is with great sadness and incredibly heavy
hearts to write that Verne passed away today.
Verne was an extremely caring individual.
He wanted to make everyone smile, be happy,
and laugh."
Actress Pamela Gidley passed away at the age
of 52 on April 16th, dying peacefully in her
New Hampshire home.
An actress since 1986, Gidley's debut role
was in the skateboarding movie Thrashin',
in which she starred alongside childhood friend
Sherilyn Fenn and Josh Brolin.
"He says they pay a thousand dollars to the
winner of some race?"
"It's no little race.
It's a downend."
Early in her career, the model-turned actress
played an android in the cult sci-fi comedy
movie Cherry 2000.
She went on to have a notable role in the
1992 Twin Peaks prequel film Fire Walk With
Me.
In 1992, Gidley had a regular role on the
buddy cop series Angel Street on CBS, starring
opposite Robin Givens as a Chicago homicide
detective.
Her last credited role was in Twin Peaks:
The Missing Pieces, a long-lost compilation
of extended and deleted scenes from Twin Peaks:
Fire Walk With Me.
Perhaps best known for playing Lois Lane in
the Superman film series, actress Margot Kidder
died on May 13th, 2018 at her home in Montana.
She was 69 years old.
Kidder moved to Los Angeles shortly after
graduating high school in order to pursue
acting.
"In the late 60s, the whole idea was to get
wildly out of control and see how far you
could go before you crashed."
In 1972, she moved to New York City and scored
a role in the Brian De Palma movie Sisters,
a critically-acclaimed psychological thriller.
But her onscreen coupling with Superman, played
by Christopher Reeve, really put her on the
map.
"Should we get on with the interview?"
"Yes, let's, let's get on with..."
The romance between the two characters played
out across four films between 1978 and 1987.
Kidder was known for a variety of other roles,
with performances in the horror movies Black
Christmas and The Amityville Horror.
The actress suffered from mental illness all
her life, and a 1996 bipolar episode led to
a high-profile disappearance.
She opened up about her struggle to Canada
AM in 2003:
"I attempted suicide several times, yeah.
I just always assumed I'd never get to be
this old, I'm a grandmother now."
As she told The Idaho Press-Tribune in 2017,
she remained actively involved in causes she
believed in, protesting against war and the
excesses of the energy industry.
"I've mostly been doing political activism…
I was at Standing Rock in a tent for four
months."
Anthony Bourdain was a writer, presenter,
producer and performer who helped shape how
we see international food culture.
He died on June 8th in France, at the age
of 61.
Bourdain rose to prominence in 2000 on the
back of his bestselling book Kitchen Confidential:
Adventures in the Culinary Underbelly.
By the time it was published, he'd already
gathered more than 20 years of experience
in the kitchen, and his unapologetic attitude
and confessional style helped endear him to
a large audience.
"Detoxing from what?
From what, a heroin addict?
I mean, go home and do some more heroin."
The book was adapted into a television series
in 2005, starring Bradley Cooper as a "bad
boy chef" based on Bourdain himself.
That image helped make Bourdain a charismatic
presence on the international food scene.
He started appearing on television as the
host of Food Network's A Cook's Tour, an adaptation
of Bourdain's second book.
Bourdain continued his career as a host with
the series No Reservations, The Layover, and
Anthony Bourdain: Parts Unknown.
His notoriety also led to winking cameo appearances
in film and television, with Bourdain appearing
as himself in the 2015 film The Big Short.
"It's not old fish.
It's a whole new thing.
That is a CDO."
He was decorated with awards from the entertainment
industry for his work, earning five Emmys
and a Peabody Award.
Bourdain tragically died of an apparent suicide
by hanging, his body discovered by a friend
and colleague in his France hotel room on
the morning of June 8th.
During his life, the chef made no secret of
his struggles with depression and history
of self-destructive behavior, remarking in
one 2016 interview: "I should've died in my
20s."
Burt Reynolds was a movie star known for his
displays of genial charm and unique charisma
over the course of his storied 50-year career.
He died on September 6th at the age of 82.
Born on February 11th, 1936, Reynolds began
his career on Broadway and television shows.
He went on to leave his mark on American cinema
through appearances in a number of successful
films, including Deliverance, The Longest
Yard, and Smokey and the Bandit.
"We have a big chance, a big chance, to make
a run for some big bucks: 80,000 of 'em."
His outsized persona and sex symbol status
made him a fixture of pop culture in the 1970s
and 80s, and he enjoyed wild success between
1978 and 1982 as the industry's top-grossing
movie star.
Despite his natural talents as a box office
draw, Reynolds spent much of his career seeking
validation as an actor, rarely earning much
critical respect for his performances.
In his 2015 memoir, he claimed he didn't start
challenging himself as a performer until he
was older, being more interested in leading
an exciting life than cultivating a body of
work.
For his work in Boogie Nights, he was nominated
for an Academy Award for best supporting actor.
He lost the Oscar but won a Golden Globe.
He also won two Golden Globes and an Emmy
for his work on the comedy series Evening
Shade.
"We got this far somehow.
You can believe somehow."
October is a month that's been associated
with The Walking Dead for many years now,
but in 2018, it brought unwelcome news for
fans of the show.
Just one day before the ninth season premiere
on October 7th, actor Scott Wilson passed
away after a battle with cancer.
The actor, who portrayed farmer Hershel Greene
between 2011 and 2014, was 76.
Wilson was a lead cast member in seasons three
and four, and he became a popular figure among
the cast and crew.
His passing was announced on The Walking Dead's
official Twitter account:
"Our thoughts are with his family and friends.
Rest in paradise, Scott.
We love you!"
In an official statement, AMC said that Hershel
was always at "the emotional core" of The
Walking Dead and that he continues to "inform
our characters' choices to this day," long
after his death.
If you're from northeastern America you'll
probably recognize the late James Karen's
face, even if you never knew his name until
now.
The character actor will be forever remembered
as "The Pathmark Man" because of an advertising
campaign for Pathmark supermarkets that lasted
almost two decades.
"So come to Pathmark.
Come to Number One!
Twenty-four hours a day, for value and savings
over all."
Karen actually lived in Los Angeles, miles
away from the nearest Pathmark store.
He passed away at the age of 94 in his L.A.
home.
The Pennsylvania native also popped up in
hundreds of Hollywood movies over the years,
including Return of the Living Dead and 1982's
Poltergeist.
Good buddy George Clooney claims Karen once
tricked him into writing his obituary prematurely,
saying:
"He just wanted to know what everybody thought
about him while he was still around.
He got a bunch of people to do it."
Emma Chambers, the British actress known for
the romantic comedy Notting Hill, died February
21st at the age of 53.
According to the BBC, she died of natural
causes.
"This is one of those key moments in life
when it's possible to be really genuinely
cool, and I, I'm going to fail just a hundred
percent."
Her breakthrough came in 1994 when she starred
in the BBC miniseries based on Charles Dickens'
Martin Chuzzlewit.
She also played village church verger Alice
Tinker on the popular BBC comedy The Vicar
of Dibley, appearing in all 20 episodes of
the show through 2007.
American audiences probably remember her best
as Honey, the eccentric younger sister of
Hugh Grant's character in 1999's Notting Hill.
She also played Helen Yardley on the TV series
How Do You Want Me? from 1998 to 1999.
Stan Lee became such a beloved figure - not
only with comics fans, but among everyone
in general - with his down to earth style
and folky mannerisms.
We all knew he wasn’t in great health, but
still in November 2018, when his own epic
arc came to an end at the age of 95, we were
all crushed.
Born in 1922, Lee's first gig at the age of
17 was as a gofer at Timely Publications.
Comic books were far from mainstream at the
time, but the success of Superman over at
DC Comics, gave owner Martin Goodman hope.
He tasked Lee with writing a story for Captain
America #3, and within the span of two years
the youngster had become editor-in-chief at
Timely, later known as Marvel Comics.
From his cluttered office in Manhattan, Lee
helped create numerous classic comic book
characters and superhero teams, from Spider-Man
and Black Panther to the Fantastic Four and,
of course, the Avengers.
Lee famously made short-but-sweet cameo appearances
in Marvel movies, with his personal favorite
being the time Thor got him blind drunk in
Avengers: Age of Ultron.
"Eggshellsior."
He told Playboy in 2014,
"Keep moving forward, and if it's time to
go, it's time.
[...] Nothing lasts forever."
It's difficult to overstate just how much
the Hollywood owes to Penny Marshall, who
died on December 17 at the age of 75 due to
complications from diabetes.
Her status as a legend would've been cemented
if she'd only been known for being one half
of the popular TV duo Laverne & Shirley.
But that was only the beginning, as her impact
on television and film went much, much further.
She became a true trailblazer for women in
show business when she directed the Tom Hanks
star-making vehicle Big, which was the first
female-directed film to gross more than $100
million.
And a few years later, she directed A League
of Their Own, which the Library of Congress
selected for preservation in the National
Film Registry in 2012 for its cultural significance.
Sadly, these aren't the only actors who left
us in 2018.
Here's a look at some of the many stars who
enhanced our lives before leaving us all too
soon.
Jerry Van Dyke
Reg E. Cathey
John Mahoney
David Ogden Stiers
Stephen Hawking
DuShon Monique Brown
Donnelly Rhodes
Connie Sawyer
Mark Salling
Robert Dowdell
John Gavin
Debbie Lee Carrington
Dorothy Malone
Vic Damone
Harry Anderson
R. Lee Ermey
Mickey Jones
Nanette Fabray
Susan Anspach
Joseph Campanella
Robert Mandan
Eunice Gayson
Stanley Anderson
Tab Hunter
Elmarie Wendel
Mary Carlisle
Charlotte Rae
Stefán Karl Stefánsson
Robin Leach
Barbara Harris
Clint Walker
Vanessa Marquez
Susan Brown
Carole Shelley
Bradford Dillman
Doreen Tracey
Christopher Kennedy Lawford
Bill Daily
Peter Benson
Derrick O'Connor
Gloria Jean
Allyn Ann McLerie
Peter Donat
Al Matthews
James "Jimmy" Karen
Diana Sowle
Yvonne Suhor
Marin Mazzie
Jackson Odell
Ricky Jay
Peter Masterson
Frank Adonis
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-273-TALK (8255)
That number again is 1-800-273-8255.